bello di ragazzi e bevete questo nuovo
video sono fi genio di salvarsi oro
chales corvino bello sicuramente è stato
un suo bellissimo sono cascato di l'ha
praticamente va bene sto dentro adesso è
dentro quella casa lì credo mai notte
adesso a volte chiusa però c'è la chiave
c'è chi è fuori anche alle scritte e
gregni di loro credito
ah beh certo intuibile mica ci sarebbe
arrivato va bene ma in tutto questo non
ho ancora visto c'erano ancora persona
che è va beh neanche io otto anni fa ma
cosa si apra altra partenza aperta ma
dai non ha stronzi avere che c'è stata
questa la prima di sotto bellissimo
trave ecco con questa ci dovrei prendere
teoricamente la chiave forse ci posso
non era chiaro perché non ci passa
neanche di ieri ha scherzato
bloccare la porta a
stronzi e che cosa che c'erano dentro
lasko teca semplicità posso passare
sotto il terre madonna ragazzi posso più
angusto augusto non esiste
o che belli scarafaggi la cosa più
piccola con il sinistro gioco per ora
perché troppi sono grossi e la gente
fischia
[Musica]
la sapevo anch'io questa stati scandali
potter ve lo giuro
non sono pazzo
chi è che ti ha fatto così esci di qua
aspetta c'è una stanza enorme bellissimo
c'è una stessa attentissima bellissimo
mercati ho fatto arrivare fin là
fin qua abbiamo aperto questo lo
distruggo fu che
la chiave
minchia 2 ora l'ho trovata siamo di
nuovo qua perfetto e ho fatto giri
strani ma poi c'è una arrivo fin là
ho la chiave adesso fosse praticamente
tornare indietro e con la chiave
teoricamente le riceve aprile questo
l'ex bomber firth my brothers
non si vedesse il programma secondo me
lui non sta proprio bene salve non è che
per caso
aspettato non poco e troppo
oh ps
avete semplice
indovinare bene quindi ogni tanto
succede a roma non so chi minh chiesto
tizio o dio benedetto benedetto ed io
ricordo salve salve buongiorno bevo bevo
bevo
la triplo cristiano ronaldo guardie fa
eco le stronze non veline ed ha già la
testa
barca perché faccio il giro
ok ma teoricamente
a minchia
però cioè
ce l'ha fatta sotto d'andata è andata a
mickey incredibile un fenomeno facebook
perfetto proprio lui a sé un'altra parte
lega sblocca perfetto
si vabbè cima altri simboli ci manca
solo quello ok non è così
questi due sono giù così è per forza
all my brothers un genio un genio un
genio 2000 e chiudo cu
2000 e cooper un gatto niente su spinta
notiamo il video perché poi la iella vi
spacchiamo anche un vetro non so jumps
kerr tra free you one that got no
tra indietro
non è cambiato poi
mai ronco ed il
san crispino vino per tutti va bene cosa
facciamo
che figata nova re basta sarò perché ci
metti due ora maneggia rastafari quindi
non guarda guarda guarda quanto lento
come la merda come nel più brutta la per
terra e corre che cazzo è un po
di culo cosa
ma [ __ ] a
minchia che capre infinita sto pezzo di
me sono cagato addosso stavolta
stavolta ma veramente fatto cagare in
mano gas
porca vacca nicchia non me l'aspettavo
mai
maronna che jobs che stufi di tutte è
che ero spinto che consiglieranno
allontanano da quello da lì perché sono
io non vado più avanti
minchiate già stavolta la casa solo
studiata bene mi sono caricato addosso
sul serio ford cava grazie grazie mille
no veramente
fantastico
clicca qua t ra qua
dai viola
sono lanciato da 200 metri mica cali ti
prego potrei morire dal ridere e 2 vado
ma una chiave
posso alzarti ti prego als al ponte o
aiutarlo cadere mi farebbe troppo ridere
dove
tra l'altro ha trovato dai tempi ero
troppo convinto di poter fare una cosa
sono morgan credibile sono pure stanco
niente sono morto sono stanco non corro
madonna
basta sculacciarmi ecco la paranza
d'ascanio vista torri
minchia chiudiamo porto che ha posto
sono tornato vero prima tutto sto
bordello perdonatelo prima fantastico
perfetto
finalmente qualcosa di allegro questo
questa è la storia da già la vedo si
stava attaccando sotto non poteva
pulirsi le cure è uscita dal bagno non è
riuscita aveva la carta igienica in
tempo perché nessuno gliel'ha data c'è
morto così d'accordo noi lo dico perché
poi successe cose io quelli che non
mando messaggi di controllare sempre
prima di pagare sempre raccomanda che
qua
è un attimo
facciamo paura in tra le stanze buie io
ogni volta sempre
di casa sisto visto gioco
locked from oro saiwa bene e j qui
giuria versata
no non ero io ragazzi lo giuro state
sbagliate
gioco grazie york a [ __ ] ma è a parte
le vomitate sul muro sono molto contenti
ha trovato una cazzo di torce alla fine
del gioco sia nello russo vedere dove
vado
sarebbe stato opportuno mettere un
attimo prima ma fa niente
a lato si si si surriscalda di turbarmi
sembra eccessivo
cioè si surriscalda lanterna ma
veramente mafai vero che una torcia era
né che se ci fosse la porta è troppo
forte eccola qua
minchia che bruttissimo fallimento
saraga scacchiera il milan ma scusate
all'epoca notte madonna che li
lasciamo andare sono io è vero
sì però ragazzi madonna d'arredamento
decente vi prego a matthew e chiara
imprese pulizia ma siamo un po eccessivo
all'interno si sta pure spiegando ciò
non vedo un cazzo
spalla 18 assi
che cazzo è successo i topi
ma che cazzo
non ho neanche capito
non ho nemmeno capito dove sono caduto
non l'ho capito cosa devo fare aiuto non
so neanche dove devo andare cosa devo
fare
cosa devo non ho capito da cosa succede
vabbè se c'è da vedere i simboli sul
muro con la lanterna che si scarica
siete scemi
triangolo
cos'è il candelabro e poi no vabbè ma
siete farsi se triangolo candelabro che
poi ce n'è un altro che non vedo
veramente
questi questo tizio che corre triangolo
candelabro e qualcos'altro ma non so
cosa
e vabbè no ragazzi non vedo niente
candelabro ecco qua catena pro con l'aci
nobili impossibile grande lavoro cosa c
è bene manca comunque uno stesso re
vabbè
è applicato 8 schiaffino hanno visto di
niente se un po mia mamma quando portavo
in quattro a casa da tempo candelabro
anche su tutti candelabri che cazzo ne
so scusi aiuto
ma ne manca uno ragazzi non lo so quale
non lo so non lo so non posso sapere non
ne faccio
non sono buono indovinare le cose
erano tre candelabri sul serio ma
veramente ma come qualcosa di opere che
questa luce
madonna
quanto tempo madonna
no vabbè ragazzi vi perdete il culo
quant'è forte
aiuto
quindi ragazzi spero che oggi sia
piaciuto chi prossimo sarà l'ultimo
episodio di james video bisogna solo
momento e mi piace anche ai social qui
descrizione si chiede come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo e ragazzi
[Musica]